[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
this ends now
what is
what is happening what is that
hey guys sorry i'm late uh nothing what
just happened
nothing to worry about
[Music]
absolutely nothing to worry about
i've never seen you run and i did
fitness with you for weeks uh-huh okay
well yep happy to have you here and
you've got your blazer on and everything
great to be back welcome back to the
break room it's uh the daily live show
from new rock stars broadcasting live
from our actual break room here at new
rockstars hq uh we're thrilled to have
you my name's zach huddleston and i'm
here with uh some super fun hosts
uh we've got the recently arrived mr
thomas bech told hello everyone give a
job interview
uh something like that i was a little
tied up i apologize i got some wrapped
up in a couple of things but
pretty sure that we have uh crossed
everything off my to-do list and i'm
just here now and uh
i got this book that uh yeah oh okay
well it's not a book club no need to go
into a lot of depth uh we've got rep and
her uh jason voorhees jersey uh jessica
clemens yo it's the best time of the
year
my favorite time of the year it is
friday the 13th and then a last-minute
fill-in and you know we're lucky rock
stars
yes we've got to fill in philip uh we're
very lucky here that that when somebody
can't make it and brandon barrack um
we don't know yeah
he was here late yeah
uh i told you that the last thing he
said to me was only i can finish this
yeah uh and then obviously i haven't
seen too many weird things happening
here we hit 100 lately
thank you uh kevin williams um who just
put into the super chat i didn't even
get to explain the super chat yet kevin
williams you had your finger on the
trigger i appreciate that let's start
this off with the
guys bear trap first that was his
shout
bang
request okay well we will
we're formally shouting out bear trap
but actually we're not doing swear jar
today kevin williams in honor of friday
the 13th whenever we hit 100 in super
chat
somebody dies what
somebody died somebody dies i don't know
i did not sign up to die at this point
yeah i mean i didn't i didn't come up
with this idea either i don't i don't
know it just kind of
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh no what just happened oh also you
think security wouldn't stop talking oh
my god coming through that door tell me
did you eat a red jolly rancher tommy
did you eat a red jolly rancher
okay well i think tommy's dead well i
guess
okay i mean this is this is unkind of me
but
the show has to go on
oh so
thank you for the 100 yeah thank you
kevin williams thanks for killing tommy
sorry we need to [ __ ] go the the the
multiple members of tommy's family are
probably watching live from rochester
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait tell me okay what do we do to bring
you back oh no no that was the last cast
okay well in addition to
tommy look tell me either you're dead or
not use the book oh use the book okay
well oh
the dork hold what the hell is that okay
i just want hold on i just want to
clarify i was just told i needed to fill
in today on the daily show
our news show where we talk about the
nerdy stuff that's in the news right
today i have no idea what the hell is
going on well i'm gonna recite this
spell and hopefully it brings back a
version of tommy
open grave one part jagermeister one
part from mince and one part irish cream
liquor shot glass uh dreamwalker go back
into tommy's body
coming up miss marvel updates galore oh
my god why did you make can you make him
less loud
no
okay what happened tell me you were
murdered i was dead yeah it was
basically still the cold open of the
show and you were already killed off i
felt nothing oh it was just a dark
dark void
you were there oh yeah that's how you
were there definitely
um we've already had a death and a
resurrection here on the break room you
guys haven't even had this show for two
weeks and i already am like what
happened to this you know what what is
happening we never should have watched i
know if you don't die
we never should have launched the week
before friday the 13th because you know
guys if this is what we do for a random
friday the 13th of may just you wait
till october okay uh but on today's show
we got christopher walken christopher
walken joins dune what an honor a friday
13th show with gore and much much more
in honor of tommy we had to rhyme yeah
tommy may or may not have wrote that i
don't know
that could have been a different uh
universe tommy you should clean up that
blood are you to clarify are you tommy
from another
dreamwalk universe 838. got it yeah and
in that one did you have a job interview
or what yes i did
i got bad news
one another one of you is not long for
this world yes every time we hit oh no
we've already hit another hundred
dollars oh my gosh you guys stop killing
us
i have so much left wait tell you wait
how do we know it's me for sure we don't
do we i hope it's not me
oh my god
it's with a dog
[Music]
don't assume the gender of the killer oh
my god
i will say right now i'm a huge fan of
this kid i am a huge fan of this killer
not that i fantasize about it but i love
jason voorhees also why so far taking
out the straight white guys too not a
typical kill yeah we're doing it
yeah hey
nice i like the way that when you get
choked you disintegrate yeah
he dusted but we can bring him back
but we believe hard enough
you got to eat that dust you got to eat
that book a little bit of phillip in my
life and then a little bit of jessica
[Applause]
a little bit of zach
zaddy coming back strong
the powers of the dark hall
have restored not one but two souls
today
the dirk hall written by judy bloom the
dark hole written by judy bloom with a
forward by beverly cleary yeah you are
probably clearly super big harry potter
yeah there's a there's a fudge uh uh
an evil demon wow i uh and we're gonna
give it away
having died and been resurrected i gotta
say it's not too different from a visit
to six flags mac duke mountain
all right anyway
charles i just really want to say a
shout out for the super chat that says
hashtag r.i.p zaddy oh oh
thank you i'll let you know daddy oh no
oh no you're from a different universe
that's right i'm i'm from a universe
where um zach is not a zaddy he's
okay what else is happening on this show
in the headlines
[Music]
get those headline graphics okay uh yeah
if if you came here for a real title
this is utter chaos this is complete
at this point if that's not what you're
showing up for i i don't know what you
okay what you are
i truly do not know what species you are
uh the first trailer we're excited about
this because there hasn't been a ton of
horror news lately but we got the first
trailer for the resident evil tv show
that's coming out on netflix it dropped
on twitter um i watch this it's like uh
kind of it feels like a reboot we got
our my dude lance reddick of the wire in
bosch fame um
uh it looks like it's great it's just a
minute it gives us almost no plot
details but it looks really good very
fun i'm really excited it started like
the main character what's her name uh no
jehovah but the
character is um claire redfield it looks
like they're taking like a different
new universe version of it yeah oh yeah
her character was not alice uh a
calendar
june uh somebody wants somebody it is
still like an umbrella thing but there
there's it's set in london i i don't
know the full pot and i don't know that
the
background
i'm still traumatized from uh playing
code veronica x as a boy that game
resident evil code veronica all of the
resident evil games are horrifying and i
refuse to play them did the movies end
up having like ten sequels or am i yeah
the last one just came out last year
yes they're still making them basically
i love the city sounds fun like uh like
where like like sonic takes place or
something
[Music]
you can keep going on the next headline
christopher walken uh
star of the dead zone a horror movie
classic a stephen king classic uh was
announced he's going to be joining uh
timothy chalamet the god and zendaya for
uh june par or dune part two
um he's gonna be playing the emperor
which if you're a fan of the june series
uh that's a very cool important role
that's gonna have a huge impact on
christopher walken look like he would be
good playing that role he has a he has
an empirical vibe doesn't he you're an
emperor i mean i just saw him in a
severance yeah and he doesn't there no
no he's not enough he looks 140 years
old in that show but uh he's still great
i think he'll have like kind of a he can
do regal menace oh you know what he can
do a little bit like um uh
andy circus star wars
no snoke kind of version of something
like
well it'd be cool if they make him 12
feet tall um oh adam so uh godzilla vs
kong is directed by this guy adam
wingard who also directed another horror
classic more recent one the guest
anybody see that throw throw throw the
guest in the chat if you saw that great
movie um and the star of that movie is
going to be joining mr wingard in
godzilla vs kong 2. it was just
announced did you guys see god's
delivery yeah i did i pretty much
enjoyed it i hear it yeah it was pretty
crazy i couldn't bring myself to watch
it i have a very stupid reason i don't
like seeing animals get hurt
even if they're giant fake animals
it escalates
is it a spoiler to talk about it now i
think the movie's been out for well over
a year technically do they just shake
hands a lot yeah it's mostly kissing
great
oh i love animals making love to each
other
and the 2006 uh godzilla or godzilla
king kong you definitely couldn't watch
it when he like rips open the dinosaurs
yeah peter jackson i just also want to
uh quick shout out to our other friend
that helped us immediately get to two
deaths arnold blake what happens if all
four die well there's only one way to
figure that out
daschle the cameraman is gonna host this
week
john and daschle and whoever's been
murdering people if we hit 500 all four
die yeah maybe that's fair that's fair
um and i guess the show's over or you
get an extra 20 minutes of empty table
we'll find out which one's more
entertaining
the wrap is reporting and this is a
funny story that bots programmed to
support zack snyder's justice league
were the most active participants in the
voting for the oscars fan favorite and
cheer moment award well now we finally
have the answer for why like the flash
was so prominently featured in the
academy awards like the flash going into
the uh what is it called the time yes
and for folks that haven't been
following along so the oscars in a
desperate attempt to be a little bit
more hip little did they know there'd be
an act of violence during their show
that would get people talking but before
that they were like oh we've gotta
appeal to the younger generation we're
gonna open two categories up to public
voting via twitter both of those
categories instantly got hacked by
snyder stans
and justice league won both of them
running away yes uh god damn well
remember they were originally gonna come
out with like best like there was gonna
be an award that actual oscar trophy
given out to like
best like fan favorite movie and then
people that were like film snobs were
like that desecrates the meaning of the
oscars the oscars is also so old that
even if they're trying to be hip they're
just going to get a bunch of trolls
they're going to get a bunch of
everything
anything to help people well and it's
also uh the oscars so yeah unhip and old
they didn't really know how twitter
works you put up a poll on twitter it
ain't gonna turn out the way you like it
did anybody not think that something
like that had happened when it was like
the flash running was the most epic
moment of all time right yeah that's a
good point um
oh we got news uh star wars and video
game fans will enjoy uh we're getting a
sequel to jedi fallen order it's coming
out uh early next year and it's
reportedly to be called star wars jedi
survivor oh nice oh i like that that
game did it really well i enjoyed it and
i freaking love that game is it a mashup
of the of the cbs uh reality show
please
i loved that game brandon is a huge fan
as well i took me forever to solve i
needed my nephew's help because i am not
great at video games his hands just
weren't made for a playstation
controller this hand was already covered
in blood when you got here by the way i
remember i noticed this is just cooling
from my this is for my morning
the blood of the kool-aid man yeah
yeah uh
sacrificed
oh yeah
and marvel knows uh disney ceo bob japek
confirmed black panther wakanda forever
still on target to release this year i
don't know you know there was some kind
of production delays we haven't seen a
trailer yet but he confirmed still
scheduled to come out november 11th you
know they were so tired of like it being
pushed or like it is coming out well and
we are going to hit this deadline and we
are going to like it and all of
hollywood right is used to the last two
and a half years everything gets delayed
all the dates are getting moved around
right so i like that they're like no no
it's
coming out you guys need to stop
whatever you're doing and do it let's
start a bet of what moment we'll be able
to tell where all the reshoots happen
and we're like rushed i think it's gonna
be a very sudden ending choice where
it's kind of like everything's headed
one way and then suddenly it's gonna be
like and with camera pan you are our new
black panther oh wow i think you're
gonna notice that like shuri has a lot
less lines and you're gonna be in and
you're gonna be like
it's gonna be like euphoria you're gonna
be like it seems like a lot is missing
here i'm very confused
we'll see we'll see yeah yeah and again
we we are desperate for trailer footage
teaser anything for that because they
have been tight-lipped on that we don't
know anything about that it's also they
keep we talked about it last time i
think yesterday about namor and was just
like they were they were like we didn't
put him in the illuminati because
he might he has other things going on in
the mcu and it's like okay so namor is
very important too to you so what is
going on i need the secrets i need the
team you think he's gonna be in the
speedo yeah
with the spock ears i'd love it uh tommy
right choice or do they go very modern
like jason momoa and he's like all
tatted up and we're wearing jeans
why not both
um speaking of marvel news we got uh a
new look at miss marvel's costume on
twitter i think we got a graphic we just
hit another 100. my god
i will i hope it's me
because i'm a big fan of jason voorhees
that's the only reason oh is it jason
that is potentially killing oh no oh no
no
um
i will never be the chosen one but i'm
not going to get mad because normally it
is the black person that goes first in
horror movies yes i am the last you get
to be the last girl yeah we should bring
him back but i'm not in a huge hurry
let's go through one more headline real
quick i mean phillip's a very busy guy
he could probably use some time being
dead but the first rest that guy's
gotten in months all right
dark cold
as i walk through the valley of the
shadow of death i take a look at my life
and realize there's nothing left because
i've been loving impression so long that
eve my mama thinks that my mind is gone
but i ain't never dropped a fool that
didn't deserve it me be treated like a
punk you know that's unheard of you
better watch where you're walking and
where you're talking you and your homies
will be lying in chalk we have tried to
bring back philip and it doesn't seem to
work please
tell me
ah
you know usually when i fill up that
hard nothing comes out that's amazing
we got
[Applause]
in my mind it was the weird owl
can i tell you guys what i saw yes
please i saw this amazing
world where
like all of the the content that we make
is just uh uh really it makes a lot of
sense and the stories that we talk about
are just what we talk about and people
follow the show so this is like april
2022 is that what you're saying before
the break room launched yeah and they're
like it just all made sense yeah they
start on time
tommy didn't work here honestly that's
the only change
this world sounds like a real utopia
okay but anyway we get to talk about ms
marvel's costume uh which you know we've
seen other angles on it before oh
there it is uh that's a nice shot there
it is um
uh again we're getting kind of a slow
trickle of information out about this
show they're kind of you know giving us
more images and posters and photo assets
speaking of outfits really quick i just
want to say fray girl hashtag small
shirt fill up this is like the biggest
shirt i own it has flowiness to it yeah
yeah look at this if you can't if you
can't see a pulse then it's a loose
shirt i could fit somebody else in here
and i'm willing to try okay
is it is it small shirt or is it just
big phillip okay
i'll never tell
that's our secret
the the man of the moment michael
waldron multiverse of madness and loki
writer uh did an interview with vanity
fair where uh he teased a continuation
of america chavez's story
either as a series or a standalone film
he had this quote uh really this is as
much about trying to drive america's
story in this film as it is attempting
to set up a mystery to be solved in the
future she's somebody without a family
that's what she's searching for
well i think that that means we're
definitely getting uh we're gonna get
more from her but they're definitely
gonna be tight-lipped on how i also
don't know if i if i interpret that
quote to be like it's a standalone movie
or a tv show i know that that was kind
of how i was distilled by a lot of other
websites but i could still see her
kind of
almost being a
the way they have treated villains in
the past where like she can kind of go
in because she is this multiversal being
she can kind of go in and out of
different films in different times and
different places and that makes her
really interesting to me even she's kind
of a uh breaking case of emergency dance
that's machina too right like oh man
you're you're moving your characters
into jam boom star portal here i can
save you from this right right
uh yeah i i think i i like that idea
like kind of how like zemo has been used
yes right or whatever like she could
kind of captain marvel at a certain
point was kind of like all right bring
her in when we really need her how do
you spice it spice her up though you
know like instead of her just being a
portal gun is she like
she decides that she's gonna go find her
her parents again i think it's yeah i
mean i do think maybe she needs
someone's help we broke a hundred people
uh
arnold blake you guys are trying to kill
literally super chatted with the quote
for jess
[Applause]
i'm gonna survive oh
oh hold on
writing a note of some sort is
[Applause]
at least and i'm going to oh no i
thought you were going to die from
getting a jason autograph i thought so
too but
i'm so happy i'm leaving a good day
today why did this time tommy
disintegrate you know it's just
different rules for your second yeah
finally chopped yes wow
uh thank you to the super chat first of
all this is ridiculous i don't know what
it says about our viewers that they
really want us to die i've never wanted
but we appreciate your generosity uh and
you know um we will mourn him till we
join him uh mr t michael bechtold
do we and i want to bring him back
you know what let's let's see how the
next uh segment goes
go forward uh yeah we're even now we're
even uh
we get thinking today because there's
this great interview with fandom.com
where the uh composer of multiverse of
madness in addition to a million other
movies danny elfman did an interview
where he was talking about how that wild
music note fight from the third act of
multiverse of madness happened right how
did they come up with that idea right
where um evil evil strange and regular
strange are fighting back and forth i
literally just came back from a
rehearsal for my one of my best friend's
wedding i'm a bridesmaid her other
bridesmaid works at marvel studios and
told me exactly about this because she
was in the meeting for this music no
fight she was like yeah i was slightly
worked on it but the biggest thing i
worked on was the music note fight and i
was like that's the fight that is the
fights of all fights so but get into it
get into it because i want to add
apparently this is 100 from the brain of
sam raimi yes and he just like uh out of
nowhere calls up danny elfman
and explains hey i want to try this
danny elfman's like i have no idea what
you're talking about i don't i don't get
how this is gonna happen and and sam's
like no no it's literally gonna be a
music fight like they're literally
fighting each other with music right and
that's how we got this and and so that
kind of got us thinking more broadly
well first off is that kind of how
you're yeah she was at first there was
no like music there also was not even a
note fight it was just like they were
like oh what is this big bad fight gonna
be about and it kind of does seem like
it's inserted in there just like music
notes i do feel bad that that we didn't
bring tommy back to discuss the life of
the party i i
i you guys know uh how important
religion is to tommy so i know there's a
page here dedicated to him all right uh
our tommy who art in hot sauce
who art in hot sauce in my bag swag
i don't i don't i can't read the rest of
this in a different way
oh my god
oh
we should have finished it we brought
him back wrong this is not correct this
goes against all laws of nature this is
the cookie dough tommy beckham
what is this
yeah
i'm sure i'm sure your microphone is
loving you're loving that yeah
it's just me oh okay oh it's so eloquent
this is the surgical masks that i have
to keep my face it keeps my face bones i
come from a universe where people don't
have bones in their face tommy okay your
job interview jacket you got blood on it
oh no
wow this mask is one eighth too small
this is really traumatizing all right
what are you talking about it looks like
you look like one of the jabber watchers
a little bit um the music fight uh from
multiverse of magic thinking of music
yeah dance fights well and that kind of
led us to thinking more broadly about
multiverse madness this this movie in
general and certainly a lot of moments
in it were some of the scariest we've
ever seen in the mcu right like this
felt the most like a horror movie of
anything we've seen
and there were some straight horror
movies some jump scares some gross out
things demons
having just recently had my neck snapped
that moment it was awesome
the first like millisecond felt like a
chiropractor visit and then the rest you
were dead yeah
yeah it felt really good then nothing i
mean in re-watching multiverse madness
when elizabeth olsen does reach out with
pat and you know snaps patrick stewart's
neck i mean i'm ever even knowing what's
about to happen i get legitimately
scared yeah he's so old be careful as
the characters the characters are not
the actors be careful with told her they
actually she actually did kill peter
what a way to go
he paid off the family they clothed him
real quick jon stewart got paid off
jimmy stewart all the steroids yeah
so they were little
this got us thinking about what are the
scariest moments in the mcu
and please in the chat share with us
what your scariest moments this can be a
scene this can be just a single shot or
moment or time or something like that uh
we have what we kind of collaborated and
came up with what we think our top five
is but tell us in the chat what you
think yours is what do we think our top
five is well we're starting off uh with
the
mysterio
tripping out uh peter with all the
illusions the graveyard and the zombie
iron man and the whole sequence yeah by
the train
yes yes there's a lot of bad things so
i've heard i don't know i've never done
drugs before
which tommy are you the one that doesn't
do drugs i'm coming from a universe full
of sobriety and good health oh that's
good to know i was stung by a bee that's
why i'm so puffy
just one bee did this
are they domesticated dogs are the size
of bees
yesterday i batted down a hive of dogs
from my tree
paddle from my boat i can't watch it i
can't watch it oh yeah you can't worry
this felt like it turned into a mysterio
illusion real quick yeah a lot going on
here real quick i want to say one like
off of that one the thing that really
got me it's not the same thing but same
vibes of just all those hands and like
the fingers hands on doctor strange in
that first movie was like unsettling to
my soul yes what was there was a movie
there was like a bus scene in one of the
marvel movies i know just because i know
the list ahead of time that we didn't
cover where like a woman turns into a
demon was that shangshi or was that uh
uh yeah in um captain marvel captain
marvel yeah oh yeah yes well that's like
a it's a scroll right yeah yeah it's
like but it looks like your name is
i have a particular phobia i don't know
what it's based on but i've had it since
a kid of like shape shifters are
incredibly frightening to me so like
kind of every scroll
hold on let's dive in here and this is i
think a great moment for tommy to uh
because he's wearing a jacket he's very
professional yeah let's get into
as a kid you were you became afraid of
shape-shifting let's talk about your
childhood how many shave shifts shave
shifters how many shoulders just
how many shapes okay
never mind jessica maybe you might be
good how many shapes shifters let's go
back to this number four is the ultron
puppet and age of ultron when he's rock
walking around
when he's all you know he does the
pinocchio there's no strings on me yes
and nothing's scarier than nothing and
there's something because it combines
kind of like creepy doll energy
with like corpses he's kind of moving
that's how benedict cumberbatch moves uh
as a zombie strange essentially yes yeah
yeah
yeah it was really effective it was
really good cgi what's the third one the
third one oh this is i would like to
take this one if you don't mind because
this honestly one of my favorite scenes
of all time
frank in ant-man poor frank getting
guilified and then flushed down the
toilet yes
this is the brand in the tank this is
that was he like a government official
or he worked i thought he worked at pym
right didn't you oh maybe that's it
right and this is like corey what stuff
yeah yellowjacket character basically
shrinks him down and he literally turns
into like a snot looking puddle of gas
yeah which is very frightening um
uh
just since we're gonna do a couple of
these shout outs probably real quick we
can call uh kevin williams uh is
reminding us of miss minutes is jump
scare
yes right that's a good yes
uh absolutely uh oh number two on our
list
loki hiring thanos as his chiropractor
in infinity war right yes
next snap did not go well for him that
was uh yeah that's male practice i mean
the timer like the purpley when his eyes
get all red and bulgy too and i mean the
foley work on that like you can hear the
bubble wrap getting twisted no
oh and now before we get to our number
one yeah are there some other good ones
there's a couple in the chat here um
ego's skull palace oh yeah he's like
lives inside that the
isn't it like the um nowhere the head of
celestial nowhere yeah oh
no that's ego
when they reveal all the day
he painted his children all over the
galaxy
[Music]
oh just the concept of people being
dusted yeah yes yeah oh yeah what's auto
about maybe we can get out of reading
i don't know what that means yeah i
don't know we can get more context uh by
dalton if you can jump on that our
number one
is the dead vision scene in wanderville
oh yeah when he's like dead vision and
he's like he's got those like gray eyes
those gray ass i this is a funny list
because realistically i guess my scenes
aren't actually scary it's just like
being buried after eating in black
panther and then going to see your dead
ones at a tree of a bunch of cats in a
tree and i'm like that would scare the
[ __ ] out of me i'm like that one's scary
i mean
getting buried alive even if you're
knowing that you're going to survive
they'll pull you back out that gets
through there's a um there's a scene in
blade runner 2049 and at the time of mcu
get back there in a second where like
the ship is like filling up with water
and it gives me a lot of anxiety yeah i
was getting the similar anxiety when
tony was running out of oxygen oh yes oh
yeah just kind of like the actual
tremendous psychological horror too i
mean i think it's easy to think about
the jump scares but when you think about
the things that like you can just in
your own life imagine like being drowned
running out of oxygen being burned alive
you guys aren't even you didn't even add
the entirety of jessica jones season one
oh my god yeah i'm getting into it
because you're so scared
yeah there's a lot of pretty frightening
stuff there and we don't we don't have
any specific moments from multiverse
madness i think we've talked about this
a little bit on the show what would you
say for you was the scariest one when
wanda comes out of that damn gong when
she comes out oh
that's like the wrong girl stop her i
said stop her the thing that made me
jump even though i did know it was
coming was on wondercore when they when
they went wong and wa and wanda first
get there and the in the the monsters
yeah the first one just
comes out of nowhere and lunges at them
that one got me good yeah i mean i think
for me it's definitely like an 838 when
they're running away from yeah and she's
doing kind of the jack torrance yeah
like limping run after them and they
shut the door and there's the longest
hold on like an unlike an empty frame
until she eventually jumped out the same
one for me too and specifically that
hold of just the like waiting that's
very much the you know from like monster
movies too the alien or whatever is
right on the other side it's like
yeah and you're like looking in the
corners of the frame you're like where's
she gonna come from where's she gonna
come from like such as sam raimi just
out of the wall
out of the way i agree uh again throw it
keep throwing in the chat we'll try to
get to him at the end of the episode
what you thought if we if we didn't name
one of uh the scariest moments for you
from the mcu throw that in there someone
said bucky killing tony's parents
i mean that's like that's like almost
like those like
uh when a stranger calls or watching or
like that whatever the visitor or the
whatever the the
paranormativity
and he's just like coldly
psychopathically kind of like going
about it yeah that's a good one that's a
good pull um and uh speaking of things
that are not scary things that are great
we want to thank our friends at
hellofresh
for helping us uh
bring you this episode hello fresh hello
um we've been shouting out hello fresh
all week long and eating hellofresh all
week long you've seen foot great home
shot footage from tommy jessica and
brandon of the delicious meals they made
you should join them in your hellofresh
adventures get yourself some farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonable
seasonable bowl i keep saying seasonable
they're seasonal
they are seasonable as well it could be
seasoned yeah and they'll give you a
little individual package yes
garlic pepper in here you snug it in
there get that delivered right to your
home with hellofresh they make cooking
easy fun and affordable yeah
we're we're saying if the next time we
talk about hellofresh we're gonna like
tell you all ahead of time the recipes
we're cooking absolutely you can try to
you know if you're already a subscriber
you can try to pick out your uh the same
ones cook them along with us maybe we
can you know you can you can be cooking
your dinner especially if you're on the
east coast and it's a little later you
can be eating with the breakfast
breakfast
very endless
options you could do and i want to
mention and this is uh in earnest even
though i look like a god dang goofball
uh
i love when you guys tag me and tag the
break room with your meals because it
reminds me to cook mine so
that's a very recent hello fresh
customer that signed up with our own
promo code talk about perks of being in
the biz uh
yeah it really helps so show me your
meals i like i'm trying to eat better
help me people yes and i'll help you
yeah it's not a perk to use the same
code that we're giving everyone okay
as a promo code or you can think of it
as an employee discount like as if you
are working at new rockstars you can you
can join up and and get the same deal
that tommy is charles valdez says philip
looking hello fresh
i got to agree
we got daddy and zaddy
by the addie boy somebody called me
fatty and i didn't like it
head over to hellofresh.com
break room 16.
use the code break room 16. for up to 16
free meals and three gifts cool thing
about it hello fresh you can mix and
match they've got this cool app that
lets you like swap out ingredients you
can do different proteins different side
dishes all that kind of stuff you can uh
pause deliveries or change delivery
dates all that kind of cool stuff
hellofresh.com
breakroom16 we thank them for sponsoring
us all week and we thank you all for uh
redeeming that code and helping us out
if you make us look good and hello fresh
it helps us put this show on thanks
right hella fresh yeah hella yeah there
it's not only hello it's hella um and uh
we also want to quick shout out our cool
merch
our our latest obsession shirt inspired
by uh multiverse of madness this shirt's
called shattered madness have we talked
about what is shattered here and what
the references no would you would you
talk about that talk about it this is
exactly dr strange's shattered watch oh
those are the same cracks and things
like that from the watch
[Music]
learned by designing that that uh the
shattered watch in multiverse and
madness does not match the shattered
watch in the first doctor
this is og
specific one but uh wow well it also it
has a bit of an element of that kind of
the the
the window
at the effect
right like uh a little bit of the same
pattern to sneak in our little easter
eggs if we can so actually uh some of
the stars that are glowing are
specifically glowing at the our hands
what have you been
and here i am the dum-dum i didn't even
realize the the depth of detail to this
this is the philip has a great eye and
is often um helping to design these
latest obsession shirts specifically as
our other uh new rockstar staff uh and
then dum-dums like me just put them on
yeah i mean maybe you don't realize all
the terrible things that are that you're
wearing on your shirt no it's a batman
shirt what madness is wrought on this
shirt and i want to know that one has a
lot of defensive nambla
the same color scheme as yours oh yeah
yeah you know in there
mine is if you washed your colors
together okay oh yeah there you go
well uh that is uh certainly
fun a little bit of fun that we've had
now today has been a very scary episode
but that doesn't mean we can't have
a little bit of fun
what kind of you say we haven't had
mandatory fun
[Applause]
i'm done with mandatory functions
sorry jason got jason just sit down
we've got a therapist here yeah uh jason
when did you first transition
oh god why does this
there you go she revoked my jason status
she's a double jason oh my god
[Applause]
jessica
jessica
i can't feel its power anymore have we
used up all the dark holes i think we've
adjusted the battery dark magic on the
dark hole is gone oh we can't bring
jessica back and that's not just because
she has a wedding dress rehearsal to go
to and has to leave it's because the
magic is gone i would never lie to you
it is not because she had to leave and
had a heart out it is because she is
dead and not coming back oh play my
graphic again
all right can we get jason in
jason come on in
there's an open seat for mandatory fun i
love that jessica loves the character
jason voorhees and jason voorhees will
replace jessica that's the break room
also jason nada known to be a verbose
character well we'll see yeah okay we'll
see because it's mandatory fun friday
the 13th is a day of evil nefarious
legends
creeps and peeps that chill your bones
discounts at your local occult crystal
shops huh
so i say let's get spooky with it
getting spooky with it okay today
all of us are gonna go around and share
our most miserable scary
movie watching experiences in the form
of a ghost story so for me
i have forgotten a flashlight so i'm
going to use my phone flashlight
and i'm going to tell you all a little
story right now
can we make the get the mood even darker
is that possible whoa is it hold on does
this do it
oh that works
oh even jason voorhees is shivering oh
jason is scared now too all right
once upon a time
in the city of angels
los angeles california
specifically sherman oaks
there was an arc-like movie theater
rumored to be owned by scientologists no
never confirmed
and a group of six arclight employees
invited their friend let's call him
jama bechtold
to a film premiere
or a special screening of a little film
called eat
pray
love
starring one julia roberts as maybe the
most selfish person on earth
not a short film
thomas sat through the movie watching
her destroy billy crudup's confidence
then take a trip to india then take a
trip to italy then go back to india then
go somewhere else javier bardem comes in
at some point and in this moment in one
of the few times in my life godzilla
being the other one me and all six
people turned to each other about
three-quarters of the way through the
movie and said
we're leaving
and we walked out of that so i like to
say i only saw
eat pray
which is what uh carnivores do that's
right wow all right who's going next
that didn't go the same direction i was
anticipating um i have one uh oh
okay thank
you haha now you're going to get
arrested by the fbi
uh
i want to take you back to the year
2005.
a lot of good movies came out maybe
people were still jiggy back in 2005.
absolutely it was still the well annie
him yeah we're still we were still close
to the millennium uh it was the obama
era right no no it was before the
obamacare uh you're a big fan of chicago
politics yeah that's right that's right
senator obama rahm emanuel was taking
over chicago by storm i went to see a
little film
called war of the world star oh starring
mr tom cruise
in a young
dakota fanning oh yeah
one of the faintings confirmed uh as i
sat down in my seats
a a movie begin to play that movie was
not war of the worlds
instead the film showing on the screen
was the 2005 bewitched film
starring will ferrell and nicole kidman
terrifying okay
you know how long until you realize i i
confusedly i look to my right and left
wait wait did i sit in the wrong theater
no everybody else furious and confused
we all paid to see where other worlds
instead they were showing bewitched okay
well clearly the projector person has
made a mistake they'll correct this
mistake
we sat through
20 minutes of being god before
eventually it was stopped and war of the
worlds began have you guys settled out
of court yeah is that or is it still
pending to this day i have never seen
the beginning of where the world didn't
show the beginning switched to reels
they just went to 20 minutes late and
i've never seen the end of my witch
[Applause]
all right uh philip you want to go i
think we'll have jason go last gosh yeah
um
i mean i thought this was gonna go a
little differently so this is a little
bit about
uh the scariest i've ever been oh in a
theater yeah some of you might know this
story oh boy or your parents told it to
you when you were young oh uh
i
discovered something about myself uh
when i was watching the film inside man
okay with one of the most deaf
uh it was most definitely a terrible
night for me i was with a
person who i was seeing at the time and
we got in a fight on the way to the
theater because i was experiencing
flu-like symptoms this is pre-coped mind
you we didn't know
and i was like you just spread that all
around yeah exactly happily and you
judge people for wearing masks that's
right uh you okay yeah oh gosh uh uh and
i did not want to go to the film
and she said well too bad i bought the
tickets and we're going and so i had to
go as i was getting feverish and feeling
terrible and uh the film starts i don't
know if you've seen it with one of these
scenes that's a flash forward to later
in the film and so it starts at the
middle of the film the big climactic
moment on a bus and as i'm watching the
movie i'm feeling more and more ill and
i'm getting
physically shaking from my fever that
i'm having in the back row and as it's
getting to the middle of the movie again
we start to return to the scene that it
started with right this the flash
forward and i start thinking to myself
this would be a perfect moment for the
movie to end even though we're only
about 40 minutes into this movie and i'm
feeling terrible and i'm shaking and i
start thinking to myself end end end
and the film melted
whoa
it melted as i was staring at it and
they had to stop the screening and we
went home you killed them
actually uh not to correct your very
scary story i'm pretty sure that was
chibi teloku for
uh baron mordo i believe was denzel's
sidekick in that movie
it's also possible that the movie was
not inside man because it was definitely
most deaf i don't remember because i
burned the film of it
but yeah that was fun though too we
didn't we didn't get a refund oh even in
the film like yeah no you know we've got
we've seen enough of it or something
like that i've got fragging chills from
that yeah speaking of uh
a chilly night uh it by uh lake
jason do you have any scary movies camp
crystal lake memories maybe
y'all seen morbius
[Music]
[Applause]
that was definitely worth miking for
uh
oh yeah we'll get the good good scary
stories
wow you know what jason voorhees doesn't
say a lot
but when they speak yeah it delivers you
listen it's illuminating it hits it hits
woo
okay uh now's the part of the show where
where we want to uh read some of the the
great chats you've been throwing out
there shout out some of our friends that
have been super chatting with us thank
you for your generosity we hit 500. oh
yeah we said we've done the show we said
we would all die if we did okay yeah no
we didn't say we done the show we said
we'd all die
okay well can we continue the show's
ghosts yeah so well in the meantime i
think jason will come back and take care
of all of us but we can give shout outs
to bryce burruss uh mark ruffalo's first
hulk out in avengers 1 natasha had the
perfect reaction to being alone with the
hulking out bruce banner what was that
reaction okay i think it was cool
perfect reaction yeah uh line of demise
uh in iron man 3 the educational videos
from the mandarin those are very scary
they're big man right like see me coming
some people call me a terrorist i like
to consider myself a teacher
they were they were very they had to
work because we didn't know it was a
fake out yeah
yeah oh um ebony ma acupuncture to
doctor strange and influence oh god
acupuncture i almost forgot a very
important thing a very nice person on
twitter reached out to me and asked me
to wish his daughter and his girlfriend
a happy birthday so happy birthday mia
happy birthday to you lisa eric and all
of us at the break room sorry i did it i
did it before the show ends i did good
i'm glad
uh
um uh super chats in there um
right on network acknowledge your tribal
chief that is a wwe roman reigns
reference and i'm here for it uh i will
acknowledge you um
charles velez saying daddy fella yes
also
an icon that's spelled differently uh
oh so we don't know anything because we
don't know
also turns out i'm not that potent of a
uh potential daddy i've learned that
about myself recently well well you know
what i'm not giving up hope we're going
to conceive that sounds like a different
horror story for a different episode or
or some freedom that's oh touche uh
contraception
david jenkins saying uh can i just say i
can't choose between fatty or zaddy let
the mud wrestling begin see again fatty
not a great nickname david but you know
what it seems like it's sticking uh oh
we're getting we're getting from off
screen uh jason voorhees is telling us
okay well uh the true murder is the end
of this show that's right we're not
landing the plane we're careening it
i think jason has to kill us in order
well maybe maybe as i outro the show
jason will will uh slowly whack us one
at a time we want to thank you all for
watching all week long joining us for
this first of uh hopefully many more uh
friday the 13th episodes oh no phillip
oh
oh great
uh stick uh we hope you watch it next
week as well we're gonna have a whole
other batch of fun episodes we thank
philip molina for guests joining us
today and again thank you to all the
super chatters and the folks watching
and enjoying and oh oh no oh no oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you